all right guys
bang bang i've got ramis here thank you
so much for doing this sir
thank you pomp and you're calling from
miami
the trendiest place to be in technology
nowadays
for sure let's jump right into your
background kind of help everyone
understand where did you grow up and
what did you do before you started the
company
yeah absolutely so i'm a proud immigrant
i grew up in india
i was born in india but i grew up mostly
in new jersey and
we just did the stereotypical thing and
moved back from the city so
i'm embracing my my roots on the other
side of it
um i spent the last uh better part of
this decade in
digital media particularly thinking
about growth and analytics
um before that i had a brief stint in in
finance
and i'll tell you what my first day on
the job
i knew would be it would be a limited uh
stint
but i put five hard years in uh in
between anyways
and and so look
i think when i think about the last
seven eight years that we've i that i've
focused on digital media
i think there's one really key theme one
thing that has just
been a through line for the entire time
and that's
this idea that uh the metrics that we
were choosing to optimize our businesses
for
they just weren't the right ones and it
grew from this kind of
intuition this inkling to something that
was just one of the
strongest points of conviction i had in
my entire personality
i spent a lot of time pounding the table
that the idea
of scale for scale's sake was wrong
in in media and you know i think we
we've kind of seen how that's turning
out and look the idea is
you can't win on scale because you're
always competing with facebook who's
going to have
a lot more scale than anyone media
company is going to build and in that
world
you have to win on loyalty on retention
on customer lifetime
and those are different metrics that
most media companies had
no experience right and if you think
about the typical media company
it was a wholesaler it was a b2b company
that sold directly to telcos or two
to whoever this new world it's a direct
to consumer
operation that needs to fight for those
customers every single day
and until we pick those metrics to
optimize our businesses
around i think media is going to be in a
tough place for years to come
yeah so let's break down kind of this um
two
really antithetical worlds right one is
let's go as broad as possible let's get
as big of an audience as we possibly can
and then the other is maybe uh we want
some scale but really what we're focused
on
is kind of making sure there's no holes
in the bucket right we want to really
work on retention and loyalty and
customer lifetime value
let's start first with the first bucket
who does that
well and then what are the downsides to
the like let's go after broad scale
type business model look i think the
people that do that well do not consider
themselves media companies
i think youtube facebook google they all
do that extremely well
and the reason they're able to do that
extremely well is they can source
content without
necessarily paying for it from every
corner of the world
and so they can serve every constituency
quite well without the economics turning
upside down
i think when you when you think about
the the other version which is
uh picking a lane and growing
meaningfully to a big scale within that
lane
there's tons of examples out there um
there's individual creators your youtube
creator that really serve
one audience whether it's marcus
brownlee or others on youtube
there's big media companies like the new
york times
and others that are focusing that
strategy and what we're seeing in the
streaming world
as well is kind of resembling that but
look i think
what makes that possible is
fundamentally the internet is a global
community and so when you say
hey we're going to target this niche
well this niche
is a whole lot more people in terms of
the addressable market than it was
even 10 years ago and certainly more and
so each niche
has a massive massive audience and by
the way
whether you have 100 people in your
audience and you charge them a dollar
each
or you have one person in your audience
and you charge them a hundred dollars
you're making the same amount of money
that dollar amount that each person is
willing to pay has kind of been
historically very underestimated for the
right product
elaborate on that a little bit right
when you say that it's been
underestimated i guess what's kind of
the historical view on
uh readers willingness to pay and then
kind of where do you think people have
been
misguided like what maybe is the actual
truth uh that you're discovering
yeah well look our data shows that
people have multiple subscriptions
for each individual subscriber and
that's even more when you think about it
at the household level
and that number has continued to grow
for the last three years
unencumbered so people do have more of
an appetite for this than
uh i think we initially thought and uh
you know this idea of subscription
fatigue
uh it hasn't come true yet what we know
will happen and what happens in almost
every
mature commerce industry is people
manage their budget they have a set
amount
and if they get this thing if they from
the grocery store they put this other
thing back on the shelf
and i don't think we're there yet that's
not what the data shows
and even once we get there there's so
much opportunity for
multiple subscriptions within that
wallet because during football season
you might have your one portfolio
of three subscriptions but then in the
spring or summer
during kind of hit movie season you
might have another portfolio
and so even if you only have room for
three subscriptions at one time
you might have room for 12 over the
course of the year
and so there's actually tons of room for
many more media brands to exist for kind
of each
use case or person or psychographic um
and
we're not there yet so let's start a
little bit about
the company that you're building today
what was the impetus for the idea and
what does the product look like
yeah well look i told you that uh myself
and actually my co-founder jonathan we
had spent a lot of time pounding the
table about these metrics
and reorienting the businesses that we
were at to focus on
uh customer funnels retention lifetime
value
well we thought wouldn't it be great if
we could help more than one company at
once
and really hence antenna was born
so what does antenna do it's a
measurement analytics company for
subscription
media businesses and it's built on this
premise
that in a world where distribution is
fixed people don't cancel their cable
subscriptions after
they watch uh football and nfl on sunday
and you just need to think about
viewership
it's easy in a world where people do
cancel
cbs all access for example the day after
they watch a bunch of nfl games
you can't just think about viewership
because you don't have a subscriber
in the first place who's watching and so
we're basically bringing all of those
metrics we've spent a lot of time
thinking about
and sharing them transparent
transparently across the entire industry
these companies have a ton of data on
their own customers
but what's a churn rate when you don't
know if it's good or bad right what's
attainable
without any sort of benchmarking or
competitive intel and by the way netflix
apple amazon they're not exactly
prone to share information like that
it's really hard to know whether you're
doing well
or not and by the way netflix can have
all the information about its own
customer as possible
when it's operating in a crowded
marketplace of other alternatives
chances are someone doesn't cancel
netflix because of something netflix did
it's because of something over there
that uh some someone else is doing and
so that context really really matters
and that's essentially what antenna
exists to provide
so this entire trend towards
subscription media obviously we see
everyone from
the new york times executing this with
millions of subscribers down to a lot of
kind of sub stacks trying to get to 100
fans a thousand fans
what's driving this trend or this focus
on subscription is it literally just out
of necessity
well i think there's a couple of things
i think once the cat is out of the bag
once netflix and spotify exist and they
show people
that they can get only what they want uh
it's hard to put that genie in the
bottle i'm mixing metaphors there
and i want to be clear there are
tremendous
benefits to bundled media
the bundle is not fundamentally bad and
it will likely exist again
at some point but the specific place we
were at with the cable bundle and the
media bundle more broadly
prior to netflix was too much content
that not enough people cared for and
there was a variety of reasons that
drove that
and so there was this incredible
opportunity for unbundling
and look people have a variety of
interests
and there have been subscription
properties that have formed with each of
those interests
and people are more or less loving it at
the moment and
the other other part of it is this kind
of price times volume
equation i laid out earlier if you're
only going to go after a certain subset
of the market
you want to drive a much higher uh
average revenue per subscriber or user
and one of the best ways to do that is
user generated revenue because the rates
there are just much higher than
advertising which is the
obvious alternative i think those two
things coming together
have really driven the boom in
subscriptions
so let's talk about kind of what the
best you know in the world or the
world-class
uh media companies are doing when you
think about retention
uh churn you know average lifetime value
what are just benchmarks or uh kind of
um
you know milestones that you think of
hey this puts somebody in that
world-class bucket
obviously i'm saying there's not that
many that accomplish this but is there
you know 90 churn after 12 months or an
average lifetime value of 200 plus
dollars
like just what's the framework that you
use to think through what's world class
and what's not
i always like putting it in this this
kind of rule of thumb
if you have an eight percent average
monthly trend rate
roughly all of your users churn out each
year
it's pretty easy when you say that and
then you ask do you think you could run
a successful business based on that
type of user uh people are like yeah you
probably
can't that's probably not a good number
and uh
you know to compare that to netflix for
example which i think people
uh widely agree is one of the best
subscription media businesses
ever built uh their monthly number is
closer to three percent
and so but there's a lot that are not
three percent there's a lot that are
close to eight percent
and so i just thinking about thinking
about that rule of thumb of
if you had your user last for less than
a year
and then they were gone and that
happened for every single user in your
user base
do you think you could build this
business i think that's such an easy
rule of thumb
and it's essentially eight point
something percent that that's the number
and so when you think through the
reasons for high churn right let's call
eight percent it gets you that high turn
is this something that the content's bad
is it that it's mispriced
like what do you see as some of the
common mistakes that media operators are
making
uh that leads to that high churn yeah
let's let's put it in
three to four different categories the
first uh you mentioned is pricing
right that's a definite category and we
see
and it differs over time for different
services but pricing
increases do have an impact on churn
rate
with some services it's a one-time
impact because they do have a ton of
loyal users
with others it's kind of a never-ending
impact where people continue to turn
because they're
they're just not as loyal and the second
is obviously what's the programming on
there
and this is really important for
especially streamers but
in a world where you're maximizing
viewership and what you want is the
super bowl
or game of thrones because if you have
one of those marquee shows you're going
to really really make your make or
breaker a year
and the way you program the way you
commission content
is dramatically different than when
you're trying to give someone
who signed up yesterday some reason not
to cancel
every day for the next year or more
it's a dramatically different
programming model and certainly
hollywood has not kind of
fully grocked that that uh programming
model but
um i think people will and i think what
you'll see there is a [ __ ]
a shift to deeper catalogs
different kind of jobs to be done of
content whether one one piece is to get
you to sign up and the rest is to
get you to stay um so i think that's
another big reason and then a third one
is brand right
who are you for this is another thing
where the old way of doing it is almost
antithetical as you said earlier to the
new way of doing it
old way drive viewership attract as many
eyeballs as possible people don't get
more eyeballs so you have two per person
so at a certain point you need more
people right
well the flip side of that is
find a niche and get them to pay you
more and more and more
they have more than two eyeballs in
terms of dollars right they can pay you
20 times they can pay you an exponential
amount more so if you
just hyper serve that one niche in terms
of your branding and you say this is who
we are for
you can do a lot better than ever before
but it is again a
contrasting philosophy to where a lot of
these folks started
and it's going to be a transition is
there a
world where you get coexistence like you
have kind of let's go after the mass
audience let's use
um cpm or cac uh type of
uh pricing for that really wide reaching
kind of lowest denominator type audience
but we're also going to supplement it
with subscription type products
or do you feel like people have to
commit one way or the other like is
there
kind of multiple models or do you feel
the best in the world
commit one way or the other pop i think
there's some
really smart harvard business school
professors that are
thinking through whether vertical
integration
uh as a strategy which is an incredible
strategy in
boardrooms is possible uh
in execution and so this idea of focus
can a telco company be a media company
can a theme park company be a media
company
all of those things um it is an
important question to ask
certainly it's harder in execution than
in strategy is it impossible in
execution i don't know
um i do know if someone is able to
execute it well it's
very valuable and let's just take it for
granted that it is possible right now
well in that strategy you do have tears
so these two things
can co-exist you do have a top of the
funnel
where it is more broad-based it is more
fleeting
the consumption is more passive and you
might be known to everyone in the world
or
certainly a large swath of people below
that
some percentage of that big audience
they might want to go deeper they might
be the hyper fans that want to meet
the personalities the creators they want
to go to the theme parks
and they want swag and those two things
can co-exist and i would say you know in
addition to
it's hard because incentives aren't
always aligned and
the place where brands that want to be
successful right now should focus
most of their time on is those building
those deep relationships
because let's face it we all kind of
know how to build big
scale businesses that playbook has been
written a thousand times over
building real direct consumer
relationships that's a new skill
that requires a lot more thinking we're
not mature in that way at all
and and so there's a lot more work to be
done there but they can coexist i think
it's hard and in that world is this when
you talk about subscription media yeah
right the the
let's go wide i think you did a great
job highlighting that's youtube that's
netflix that
um or i'm sorry uh youtube facebook
twitter all of those
but in subscription we've really only
seen kind of two models
one is a hard paywall where i'm going to
ram you into the paywall
and there's written content or there is
video content right and so you see on
the written side
obviously the new york times has done a
great job of this business insider
there's a bunch of these businesses that
have really started to kind of figure
out how to grow that subscriber base
on the uh video side you've seen things
like masterclass you've seen netflix
what we haven't heard a lot about is
subscription podcast or audio for
example
i feel like people have pontificated a
little bit like oh that should be a
thing because there's written content
there's video like why not audio
but we haven't seen anything really
really work yet
is that just the market hasn't matured
yet or is there something else that's
kind of holding that back from
developing
i don't know if it's if you call it
original sin in the podcast
and by the way just taking a step back
and the way we define kind of consumer
entertainment
i think there's two things that really
differentiate us from the nielsens of
the world and what others do
the first i've really highlighted it's
this this focus on purchase behavior and
not viewership
the second is how we define consumer
entertainment right it's not just big
horizontal media
it's gaming it's audio it's
user-generated content it's edutainments
or infotainment as masterclass might
think of them
it's health and wellness and so if
you're a consumer you are making
trade-offs not just between hbo max
and netflix um but between hbo max
netflix and masterclass and maybe
peloton so
that's kind of the second edge in which
we think uniquely
to go back to your original question on
podcasts i don't know if you'd call this
original
sin or not but one of the original sins
of the podcast industry
was that these incredibly talented
creators
who often went through big media brands
and
used advertising as their primary method
uh of funding their podcasts and i think
where that goes
is a platform i think spotify is really
making a push here
captures a bulk of the value as they
build tools and automation into the
system
right and so the logical end for for
podcasting right now
is an ecosystem where there's
unbelievably talented creators a
plethora of them
there's a discovery and monetization
layer
it might be spotify and that discovery
and monetization layer
captures a bulk of the value because any
individual creator
struggles to stand out or have leverage
there i think
the biggest creators will likely then
circumvent that or use that
as a marketing tool and i know i'm sure
you think about this all the time i know
sam harris thinks about this and i know
others do
but for someone who has the level of
engagement and brand and depth of
relationship
spotify in this example it doesn't just
become your
only monetization layer it becomes your
marketing funnel
and it might be audio products but it
might be non-audio products and there's
a whole set of vertical monetization you
can create there
but that's not going to be available to
everyone and i think for someone to just
say hey i'm going to do a podcast and by
the way it's going to be paid
is going to be really tough because
you're basically competing
with a ton of free stuff out there and
not in a differentiated way
but you know to contrast that with
something like sam harris's meditation
app which is a
an audio driven experience
there's gonna be a huge market for
things like that in my opinion
um so i'm not sure if that makes sense
but i'm sure you've thought about it
quite a bit as well no look i think that
makes a ton of sense and to me
really it just comes down to uh are you
optimizing for
only economic benefit or are you
optimizing for other things as well
right and i think that this kind of
idea of having multiple products for a
brand or an individual really drives a
lot of that as well because there is a
trade-off if you want to optimize for
revenue
yes you should go subscription only and
you should go get people behind that
paywall over a long period of time
but that does kill a lot of the virality
that kills a lot of the growth and
things like that
so i think maybe sam's probably one of
the people who's figured out kind of
this uh
medium uh ground where you know some of
the episode is
out in front of the paywall and then hit
you with the hard pay well if you listen
to the rest you gotta go pay
um so i think that there will be more
innovation there uh but but it is a
very interesting thing cause i think
there's people like luminary and others
who have kind of taken stabs at it
but no one seems to have really nailed
it i know andrew wilkinson and a bunch
of people
working on super cast they're trying um
and that platform is pretty interesting
so we'll
see what happens um i want to talk a
little bit about your guys platform uh
tell us
you know kind of if i end up coming in
and i use the product like
how does the product actually work and
what are the insights that i can glean
from it that maybe i wouldn't be able to
get out of google analytics or some
other
analytics service yeah of course so it
is focused on purchase behavior
and subscription metrics and so if you
are a streamer
and you want to benchmark any of your
key metrics against the market
signups trial conversion churn rate
retention
etc you would come to us and you'd be
able to do that and you'd be able to
track that over time
beyond that you might have amazing first
party data
um and you might know your own churn
rate i hope you do but
what you don't necessarily know is how
is my churn rate impacted by other
market events
a big promotion at one of my competitors
a big programming release
a new launch of a service what we can do
because we can go much deeper
is say what's the netflix churn rate
for users who also signed up to disney
plus in the munch that month that it
launched
versus the churn rate that did not and
so netflix would then know oh wow
users who sign up to disney plus are x
percent more likely to switch
and so that competitive intel and then
lastly
and again it's because of the depth of
the data
understanding how to make it's not the
silver bullet anyone that tells you they
have data that is
run fast away but decisions like pricing
content valuation
promotions and offer strategy
distribution
understanding for example what's the
difference in
churn rates between the app stores the
channels environments true direct
consumer billing
and where should i focus most of my
marketing and product teams time
based on that what's the customer
lifetime value profile of each
and that helps you make those
distribution and product decisions in a
way that
hasn't been available in the market
today because look none of the platforms
are
really apt to share much data if you go
talk to apple and amazon they don't
share
a whole lot with their partners yeah
it's absolutely fascinating and how are
you guys collecting this data i think
that's one of the things people
are always fascinated by like you have
so much data that's so robust
how exactly are you capturing it
i'm glad you asked i think it's a really
unique data strategy because it allows
us to provide day zero value
we're not asking you to give us your
data in order to provide something
and i think that sort of you know going
a different direction i think that sort
of kind of
long sas integration process always
kills
software startups early days and we're
partnering with a number of
really popular consumer apps and those
apps might help you manage your budget
or clean up your inbox and
those apps are generally free consumers
opt in very explicitly
to share certain data transaction data
email receipt data
and kind of other psychographic data um
with the apps and their partners and so
what we're getting
it's anonymous but it's persistent over
time user123 signed up to netflix two
years ago they canceled netflix 30 days
ago
and they immediately signed up to
peacock that's how we're putting the
metrics together and
what i love about it is at the end of
the day those consumers that are sharing
the data
they're actually getting a value because
these companies that provide them the
entertainment they love
day in and day out are making smarter
decisions
because of the data they're providing
which i love that it's kind of a virtual
virtuous cycle at the end of the day
you guys have built this this amazing
product uh but you've raised capital
you've put a lot of really smart people
around the table talk a little bit about
the fundraising strategy to date
who the investors are and kind of the
logic behind partnering with those
investors over others
yeah so we raised a little bit over 4
million dollars and it was
led by a fund called rain ventures
they're the vc fund of a really big
media
merchant bank called the rain group
which a lot of people know
and a ton of great angels supported as
well
including a bunch of media and
technology founders executives
and we did that um a few weeks ago
actually
and it was like fundraising is not
success
but it certainly allows you to hire and
operate
to get there and there's a couple of
reasons why
we really thought now was the right time
to fundraise
and i think uh it'll sound familiar to
to people who have built successful
startups before we're early in our
our journey but you can feel this moment
when you have
uh momentum and product market fit uh
and i'll put it in maybe
four phases the first is i don't know if
i can curse in this podcast but [ __ ] it
let's try some [ __ ]
uh right that's the that's the precede
phase maybe
the second is hey this problem we have
identified is
real it is valuable and people really
care whether or not we have the right
solution i couldn't tell you
the third is hey our product is starting
to push some of the right buttons
for this huge problem we've identified
and the fourth is whoa it's working
scale
scale scale build process i would say
we're very early on in the third one
um the problem we've identified
definitely exists the urgency is there
we've heard it
countless times hundreds of times
and some of the things we're doing might
not be it but it's in the neighborhood
and we know that this focus on purchase
behavior
is what people are interested in we know
that this data is not easily
available other places we know people
are trying to make pricing distribution
decisions
and they feel naked in terms of the data
that they they have
and so because we feel like we're at
that kind of beginning of the third
cycle
we thought look we need to raise some
money right now to accelerate building
our own product
so we can recognize this incredible
urgent problem that we've identified
and that's kind of the rationale for why
we did it rain
stands for themselves in terms of why we
chose to partner with them
and so i won't talk too much about them
but only a couple weeks in and
they have blown me away in terms of
their sophistication and
how leaned in there i love it um talk to
me about how you guys make money a lot
of people hear this they'll say hey the
product's amazing you've got great
partners how these guys plan to make
money
um our customers subscribe to the data
and essentially it's syndicated research
which is a bunch of reports essentially
and raw data
as well as some analyst hours and the
idea and how market measurement has
worked in
a number of paradigms and industries
before us is
we provide this data that's
differentiated and we stamp it with our
kind of seal of approval so the
methodology is very well understood and
trusted
and our customers build ip around it
so they think about the right questions
to ask of the data
and they ask those questions over and
over and look their competitor might not
be as crafty or smart
and that's kind of the value that the
data brings but even when everyone has
it
there's more value on top of that
because
there's some groups that are really
smart in how they use the data and so
that's kind of how we make money and why
it's valuable long term a uh a
subscription business model for somebody
who analyzes subscription models exactly
very meta
very mad absolutely shocking and by the
way by the way on that note
i think a lot of people like the idea of
a subscription business model
because hey recurring revenue is cool
that's a great outcome but i think
people should
start to analyze that problem a little
bit more from first principles
for us the reason a subscription made
sense is that the market
changes every day every week i mean just
the streaming market alone
you have hbo max putting all of their
movies
direct to uh direct to s5 warner media
putting all their movies direct hbmx
and you have disney releasing a dozen
pixar and marvel movies direct to their
platform
uh you have paramount plus and discovery
plus launching in just a few weeks
every day every week every month there
is a new story
and so if we were just to do one time
engagements um our customers would miss
a lot of how that
changes and in a world that's this
dynamic you don't wanna you don't wanna
be left out on that
yeah that's so fascinating uh before i
let you go i always ask everyone the
same two questions
you'll get to ask me one to uh to wrap
us up here uh the first question is what
is the most important
book that you've ever read and i'm gonna
change it uh
what is just the most important
subscription business that you've
uh either paid or content you've
consumed from
um awesome that's a good question
i have to say strategy which is ben
thompson's
uh i i would call it blog but it's
really much much more than a blog
and i'm sure you've gotten that answer
before
strategy for me was the foundation of
how i understand the world today
when it comes to media and technology
which is by the way what i spend more
time thinking about than any other one
thing in my life
and it really was it's stemming from
this idea that in a world
where everyone is your audience
and reaching everyone in the world is
extremely cheap with marketing platforms
like facebook or google
getting a huge audience is not valuable
because anyone can do it
and so if anyone can do it how do you
build value
the way you build value is to create
deep lasting relationships with users
such that they stay retained and they
continue to
pay you money such that their customer
lifetime value is bigger
and so it really ties back to what i'm
doing right now with antenna
and so i have to credit credit ben there
for that
that's a fantastic answer uh aliens
are you a believer or a non-believer i'm
sure you've read tim urban who runs
weight but wise fermi paradox
i i just don't know how you could read
that and not believe in aliens
and then when you look at the complexity
of the world today and you look at how
insufficient
uh human iq or the way we approach it
is it just it has there has to be more
right
listen i'm a believer everyone knows
that i believe uh i don't know
been to earth i don't know if we're
gonna meet them i don't know if they're
little green men
but i definitely think there's
intelligent life somewhere in the
universe it's just too big
uh but you know the more granular you go
into some of the conspiracy theories
maybe i'm not there
uh but that's okay
[Music]
uh you could ask me one question to
finish up what do you got for me
do you want a bitcoin question or a
non-bitcoin question or should i ask
both
go ahead fire away with both awesome on
the bitcoin question
look the internet was created with the
idea that there is no scarcity there's
zero marginal costs for distribution
yeah you guys are all obsessing with
this digitally scarce
property i don't get it tell me why
those two
things can simultaneously exist
yeah well i think that the whole key to
this is
uh basically it comes down to
provability right so the idea was always
the internet take a music file for
example if i said to you hey
uh you know or i had a music file and
you wanted it you said that new kanye
song
i hit press send and the way that the
internet works is basically they would
copy the file send it to you you didn't
know if you had the original or the
uh kind of copy and neither did i didn't
matter like listen to the song you'd
listen the song everyone was happy
uh when you now want those digital files
to represent
assets whether they're stocks bonds
currencies or commodities
you need proof ability you need
authenticity you need to be able to
prove scarcity right that's what makes
the financial assets work
and so you can even argue that there's
scarcity in
the existing financial system right in
terms of everything is an electronic
qsip
it's just in a centralized database so
it's really no different than
using electronic q-sips the difference
here is there's not a centralized
database there's a decentralized one
and so i think that you know it's kind
of one of these weird things like
something isn't a thing until it becomes
a thing and that's like a perfect
example
um so you know it's uh it's unique but
uh but it's working so far and so
i tend not to try to overthink it and
just say hey it became a thing and i
don't think it's gonna stop and
i don't want to short that trend awesome
i i love that
answer okay my non-bitcoin question
which i think is the most important one
and a great place to close
and i'm sure you did too but i think we
both grew up in a world where
uh leadership was defined by alpha males
ruling by force
you actually get to a position of
leadership and you realize that
you're a servant to your team and
decision making is so decentralized that
you need
all of them to feel like owners and
leaders it takes a tremendous amount of
eq
and it's something i think you're
uniquely equipped with but tell me what
are the
what are the secrets or what's one
secret that you use to get people to
open up and be so
uh free of any sort of walls or guards
when they talk to you
well i think there's two things so we
specifically talk about like people that
i work with
uh one of the you know big rules and
kind of lessons i learned
in uh in a lot of these military
leadership schools was always the idea
that the leader eats last and it's such
a simple concept right but it's
basically like
your job is to take care of everyone
else and you eat less and so literally
when i was deployed in iraq
like we would go to the chow hall to eat
and you would see sergeants or officers
wait and they would
literally count all of their guys going
up to go eat you know these are coming
off infantry missions dudes are
starving also everyone else eats first
then i'll eat
and it comes from a world of like hey
there might not be enough food left type
situation right but
it's still this idea that like i am the
least important person here because you
are
as uh as the person that's being led uh
doing the activity right and so you are
much more important
the the second thing um that i'll kind
of uh
highlight is that i forget who it is it
might be daniel act i can't remember
but rather than um be a pyramid
uh recently in paulina's the profile it
talks about
uh inverting the pyramids a lot of
people think like i'm at the top of the
pyramid i'm the most important person
but if you actually invert it and think
about i'm the bottom of an
upside down pyramid now all of a sudden
i am here to basically serve everyone
else above me um and so that's like a
really unique kind of visual framework
um and the last thing in terms of
getting people to open up is i just ask
them what they care about specifically
when i
work with them right and i say them like
what is your goal right
i just went through this with a couple
of guys that i work with and i
specifically said what's your financial
goal for 2021
right where do you want to be in three
to five years what is your career goal
is that you know as a stepping stone in
your career what you're doing today
what's the path to to getting there
and i'm surprised that many people just
don't ask that and so i've got some guys
who
they want to make a ton of money like
that is their goal
and they've got specific numbers and
like let's go help them try to hit those
numbers
i've got other people who want to
develop skills or learn new things or
whatever and so
across all the businesses that i have
like i just try to understand like who
is this person what are they trying to
accomplish
and if i can empower them to accomplish
that goal then ultimately like they're
gonna be happy
and i'm gonna feel good because i've got
a bunch of people who have been
successful in accomplishing what they
want that i work with
and so it's just a win-win that's
that's a really incredible answer so we
can leave the audience with two things
one ask people what you what they care
about when you talk to them and
two leaders eat last
that is uh that that is definitely true
where can we send people to find you on
the internet or uh or find more
about antenna yeah my twitter is
twitter.com slash remise tasse
r a
e and antenna dot live l-i-v-e is our
website
you uh your twitter feed is full of
insights around media and subscription
businesses so highly highly recommend
and folks can go check out the product
but uh listen thank you so much for
doing this let's do it again in the
future
awesome pomp happy holidays